the gunman accused of killing three
co-workers at a Maryland office park and
injuring three others is in custody this
morning
rowdy Labib prince was arrested in
Newark Delaware last night after a
manhunt that led police up and down
Interstate 95 Errol Barnett is in
Edgewood Maryland where the shooting
spree that spanned two states began
arrow good morning good morning the
terrifying incident began here Wednesday
morning as people were showing up for
work at this office park the FBI says it
does not appear terrorism related and
that Prince knew every one of his
victims in both states a very sad day we
came to a successful conclusion last
night authorities ended a ten hour
manhunt for 37 year-old ruddy Prince in
Newark Delaware people saw her come
around building crying Kevin Doyle was
one of the first to call 9-1-1 Wednesday
morning after Prince allegedly opened
fire on his coworkers it took place at
this countertop company in Edgewood
Maryland Prince killed three people and
put two others in critical condition
figure somewhere did because OMI always
seemed to bring more personnel police
said Prince then drove a black 2008 GMC
Acadia SUV like this one about 50 miles
along the busy traffic corridor of i-95
that's when more than 60,000 people
drive between Maryland and Delaware
every day Prince continued his spree at
this used-car lot in Wilmington Delaware
where he shot and wounded another victim
this is a desperate person he's already
killed three people
he shot six all together and he's still
at firearm honor Wilmington Police Chief
Robert tracy said officers received tips
from the public and found Prince walking
near a high school police chased him on
foot after he tried to discard a handgun
matching the caliber of bullets found at
both crime scenes
last night reporters asked Tracy how
Prince a convicted felon who has been
arrested 42 times in Delaware alone was
able to walk the streets if there's
violent people that are causing carnage
in the community and have some violent
crimes we've got to find a way to keep
them behind bars now CBS News obtained a
restraining order that a former beau
sought against Prince in February
claiming he punched another employee
Prince will be arraigned as expected to
face charges in both states and
eventually move back to Maryland Nora
all right Errol thank you so much